you mentioned that the fear of boredom
might be a kind of proxy for the fear of
death uh so what role does the fear of
death play in The Human Condition are
you afraid of death
yes I think everybody are afraid of
death I mean all of fears come out of
the fear of death but the fear of death
is is just so deep and difficult we
can't usually we can't face it directly
so we cut it into little pieces and we
face just little pieces oh I lost my
smartphone that's a little little piece
of the fear of death which is of losing
everything so I can't deal with losing
everything I'm dealing now is losing my
phone or losing a book or whatever
somebody I I feel pain that's a small
bit of the fear of death somebody who
really doesn't fear death would not fear
anything at all it'll be like anything
that happens I can deal with it if I can
deal with death this is nothing so any
fears and as a distant echo of the the
big fear of death have you ever
looked at it head on caught glimpses
sort of contemplated as the stoics yeah
I mean and when I was I I was a teenager
I would constantly contemplate it trying
to understand to imagine it it was
extreme it was a very very
uh shocking and moving experience around
a special in connection like with you
know with with national ideology which
was also very big strong in Israel still
is
which again comes from the fear of death
you know that you're going to die so you
said okay I die but the nation lives on
I live on through the nation I don't
really die
and uh you hear it especially on
Memorial Day Day for fallen soldiers so
every day they'll be in school Memorial
Day for fallen soldiers who fell
defending Israel in all its different
Wars and all these kids would count rest
in white and you'll have this big
ceremony with flags and songs and dances
in memory of the Fallen Soldiers and you
get the impression
um again I don't want the sun crash but
you get the impression that the best
thing in life is to be a falling Soldier
because even though yes you die
everybody dies in the end but then
you'll have all these cool kids for
years and years remembering you and
celebrating you and and you don't really
die and I remember standing in in these
ceremonies and thinking what does it
actually mean like okay so if I'm a
fallen soldier now I I I'm I'm a
skeleton I'm bones under this in this
military cemetery under this stone do I
actually hear the kids singing all these
patriotic songs if not how do I know
they do it maybe they trick Me Maybe I
die in the war and then they don't sing
any songs and how does it help me and I
realize yeah as a quite I was quite
young at the time that if you're dead
you can't hear anything because you
that's the meaning of being dead and if
you dead you can't think of anything
like oh now they're remembering because
you're dead that's the meaning of being
dead and it was a shocking realization
but it's a really difficult realization
to keep holding your mind like it's it's
the end I lost it over time I mean for
many years it was a very powerful fuel
motivation yeah for philosophical for
Spiritual exploration
and I I realized that the fear of death
is is really a very powerful drive and
over the years especially as I meditated
it kind of dissipitated and to die
sometimes find myself trying to
recapture this teenage fear of death
because it was so powerful and I just
can't I I tried to make the same image I
don't know it's it's
something about the teenage years yeah I
always thought that the adults there is
something wrong with the adults yeah
because they don't get it like I would
ask my parents or teachers about it and
they well yes you die in the end that's
it but and on the other hand they are so
worried about other things like they'll
be a political crisis or an economic
problem or a personal problem like with
the bank or whatever they'll be so
worried but then about the fact that
they are going to die ah we don't care
about it that's why you read kamu and
others when you're a teenager you really
worry about the existential questions